it was a site not seen since 9 11.
thousands of planes grounded at all U.S
airports due to a Nationwide stoppage
called by the Federal Aviation
Administration no nothing like this
since 9 11 obviously you know everything
just stopping because of the system I
think they should just punch control or
delete
the FAA says a computer failure was to
blame specifically the notice to air
mission system or not M suffered a
temporary outage without it flight crews
could not access the latest safety
alerts about fly conditions and runways
we still consider this to be a vital
safety system because this is the one
that moves messages that Pilots need on
anything from a taxiway or a Runway
being out to an issue with the
navigation Beacon to maybe an upcoming
military or space operation in a certain
sector
the outage did not impact flights
already in the air the ground stop
lasted about an hour and a half until
the FAA said the computer problem was
fixed the cause of the outage remains
unclear there is no direct indication of
any kind of external or nefarious
activity but we are not yet prepared to
rule that out
President Joe Biden has ordered an
investigation the White House says there
is no indication of a Cyber attack the
FAA is working aggressively to get to
the bottom of the root causes for the
system outage so that it does not happen
again meanwhile thousands of delayed or
canceled flights have colored flight
status boards at airports red this is
the domino effect of the ground stop and
it's impacting Travelers already
battered by a chaotic holiday travel
season
Wilford Smith hopes his flight from
Washington to Fort Lauderdale Florida
will take off on time his wife is
waiting there he says and he hasn't seen
her in a long time oh my first thought
was freaking out
it's like oh I haven't seen her in five
months and now
it may be a day or two more that an
apparent technical glitch can halt the
U.S air travel industry impacting
Millions has drawn renewed scrutiny to
the system's vulnerabilities a full
investigation has been promised Heidi
Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington